this video obtained by the washington
post
shows just how few police officers there
were to keep
rioters some armed with restraints and
weapons
from getting to members of congress
members say when they were trying to get
out the last available exit there were
only three officers holding the line
trying to give them enough time to
escape when they stepped aside
as a window was broken a rider was shot
the representatives and their staff
escaped
this video was captured by a reporter
for the huffington post
rioters looking for the senate he says
if they had turned right
they would have entered the chambers
with senators inside
this lone capital police officer
directed them away from it
and up the stairs instead but not
everyone was this confused
one congressman says there is evidence
some had planned their attack
there is a mock office there's
officers got my name on the door but
they didn't bother that
office they went to the office where i
usually work and where i usually am
my staff was in my office
they had all the furniture and stuff at
the door
and there were people trying to get in
we're going to the capitol
the president directed these followers
to march on the capitol
he told them the election was stolen and
now democrats say he should pay for
inciting an insurrection
they are moving to impeach him within
days our main priority is to ensure the
removal
of donald trump as president of the
united states every minute and every
hour that he is in office represents a
clear and present
danger not just to the united states
congress but frankly to the country
but not all republicans are on board
some using the same reasoning that they
did after the president was impeached
the first time
my personal view is that the president
touched the hot stove on wednesday
and is unlikely to touch it again many
say an impeachment will only divide the
country further
but some argue it's necessary for the
long-term health of the country
until the united states starts taking
steps to hold
those who both participated physically
in the actions but also
incited the actions and aided them until
we see accountability for
all of that and a renewed commitment
among mainstream republicans towards
democratic norms and values
i'm afraid we should expect that this is
only the beginning of
the rise of trumpism and perhaps even
further violence
it's unclear if legally the senate can
hold an impeachment trial for a
president who's already left office
the courts will likely have to decide
that but it does seem likely that in the
coming days the house of representatives
will make sure that donald trump
is the only u.s president to have been
impeached
twice patty culhane al jazeera at the
capitol